why um don't you film your sets for
social media like other comedians are
doing one is because I don't want other
Comics to see it and two there's Magic
on stage with me there is do you agree I
agree there's magic I agree and I don't
want to see it again because every time
is a new beginning every show that I do
is a different show and if you see one
if you see your set guess what you're
going to try to repeat that again so I
take what I do in track and anything in
life when I ran track and I was
good just because I was good last week
don't mean I'm be good this week so I
took that through my whole life and just
because I was funny when you saw me that
don't matter no more can I be funny PL
tonight but you got to find different
ways to like say when if you had to be a
boxer right right if you're a boxer you
know you could beat this person but you
know what today I'm
tired I can't deliver that same energy
or the audience is different but if you
still find a way to be clever still find
a way to be funny
entertaining yeah work in the crowd work
the crowd sitting in front I you you
were clowning on these guys in the front
row these young D hilarious oh my God it
was hilarious and long as the people
walk out entertained right you were
hilarious so I think the other end of
that is or the other side of that coin
is if I saw you do what you did to those
kids yes that were sitting in the front
row that there was three single young
men right um if I saw that on Tik Tok or
or on Instagram and I didn't know who
you were right I'd be like yo I need to
follow this guy cuz that was great and
then I might be inclined to go see you
live absolutely cuz there are some
comedians who do do crowd work and they
show that but when you go see them
they're not that funny because that's
not the same situation that's going to
happen that night true cuz the crowd's
always going to be different it's always
going to be different cuz like you see
like uh have you heard of Matt r no I
haven't so Matt R uh he's doing like he
he's had a very like insane come up the
last 12 months okay so he has he has a
Netflix special but he blew up off of
his crowd work bits going viral on his
Instagram and on and he's a good-looking
young dude okay oh I know somebody used
to manage him okay yeah just talking
about him last time good looking young
guy and but he's very much new and I
mean it's a meteoric kind of rise in the
comedy world I've heard other comedians
talk about it like you know like it's
kind of unparalleled how fast he's come
up yes cuz he didn't have to go through
the bumps and bruises of you know
performing for 10 people right and and
before you even tell me what happens I
can tell you what how his career is when
you watch him I bet you he's not that
funny well I saw it standable it was it
was it was it was it was okay yeah it
was mediocre because not that he won't
be funny right he hasn't put the time in
to funny to be a great comic you need
years of experience you have to
experience life you have to go through
things that's why when you saw Richard
prior he talked about this drugs his
situation what made it funny cuz he was
living life if you're 20 something years
old oh you ain't lived right you talking
about sneakers and condoms maybe and
smoking a little weed but you Haven been
lived and when you have lived and you
have experience after experience after
experience you keep you more material
it's almost like if you're once you're a
rapper it's like once you hit a certain
level of success it gets harder and
harder to draw inspiration to make music
that is relatable to the people
absolutely because you're older now and
rapping believe it or not is a young
kid's game right it's it's almost like
when Jay-Z did 444 it was like oh [__]
right he made like an album for like a
40-year-old [__] who's like
doing grown man [__] which is hard to do
and it be accepted yep yeah it's so true
so that's how that the game is but um
it's good to see from when I started in
1985 it's good to see so many different
ways you can make it in this business
like the gentleman you talking about or
for crowd work um it's also great to see
that the audience the fans are starting
to tell what is a
gimmick I feel like the gimmicks are
going going away it's about the it's
about the jokes yeah it's about the
quality because they're getting tired of
being played that the I saw you on Tik
Tok you was hilarious and I come to your
show I spent
$175 $200 and I I didn't get what I
wanted out of your show it's like 50
Cent 50 Cent is going on these world
tours and all these young rappers can't
do canceling they got canc they
canceling it I saw I went to the 50 tour
and I was like you know I've been to
shows that were better I've been to
shows that I as a younger man you know
as a younger hip-hop fan but I don't
remember a show in the last 10 years
that I was
more just I just had such a good time
wow CU I was like gives a great show 50
is an amazing performance
and he's like we don't we're like like
that era we don't get to see those guys
tour right that's so true anymore right
y so it's like you know to get a 50 Cent
tour where he's doing get rich or die
trying and and and it's just like it
just took me back it was like you know
like we don't get those mega mega mega
hip like you were talking about the Cash
Money ref rer story like the days of
that [__] is like people are it's like I
feel like everything feels like a cash
grab yeah I totally agree and that's sad
and even in the comedy world is a cash
grab people will come to your show like
I don't charge to take pictures after
the show I've seen that yeah and people
will charge you all that money a meet
and greet a meet and GRE yeah you you
charging them for a meet and greet
that's a cash grab and it's deeper than
that to me yeah it's deeper than that
I'm saying thank you let me shake your
hand and I'll see you next time I'll see
you next time I want to hold you I want
to hug you because I want you to come
back and I want you to know I appreciate
you spending your hard earned money to
come see me you had to go get a
babysitter you had to tell somebody um
you'll be back in a few hours you're
going to go see TK Kirk I understand all
that I don't want to rob you like that
right you know I want to charge you for
my tickets give you a great show and
have them leave the same way give you a
memory you take a picture exactly you
know so that was it and you were so
genuine cuz you know you can look
someone in their eyes and when you came
out of the show you I just saw it in
your face like you was truly pleased for
sure yeah you know and that's what I
love yeah that was I mean like I said
dude I I like going to the store
sometimes cuz I'll be able to watch like
10 guys right I'll be able to eat wings
have drinks maybe like three of the 10
I'll love you know but to like sit down
and just be like oh [__] this I felt
like I just went to church right yeah I
was I I get on it I get on it and like I
said I dropped the knowledge then you
saw the fun then you saw the personality
then you saw the appreciation meaning
shaking your hands afterwards saying
thank you like a pastor for sure that's
what it was